he won the PGA Championship last year he
won yesterday in Akron Ohio he is Justin
Thomas who joins us on the program good
morning Justin congratulations welcome
to the program thank you okay before we
get started official height and weight
for Justin Thomas I know what you're
listed in the program ass
I need official heightened weight
160 yep I put on put on it get rid of
weight last year so I'm no longer on 45
okay we also had a bet on how much you
can bench B over/under is your weight at
160 I really don't know I haven't I
haven't done the bench press in a while
I'll do some dumbbell bench every once
in a while but I haven't kind of thrown
us Wow so I don't know I'd say it's
pretty safe it's pretty good fat but I
wouldn't be surprised if I can get it
but I thought everybody's getting all
jacked up now Justin yeah you know I'm
strong in the right places I prefer golf
that's for sure but I'm not exactly
throwing any weight around that's for
sure
I'd explain to the audience and to me
that with your size you can hit it as
far as anybody so be key for us weekend
golfers to get more distance using your
philosophy Justin Thomas would be one
well the most most important part is you
know I tell amateurs ask you out all the
time and Carl answers such as I mean yet
did it solid most importantly so that's
mm-hmm that's it's something that's
obviously a lot easier said than done
but I mean for you to get the most out
of your distance or the most out of what
your swing gives you you know hidden in
the center of the club is always going
to be most important but but for me I
use the ground really well my head can't
can't hurt anything I wouldn't exactly
teach that or tell anybody to try it but
it's just something that I've always
done and it works for me
what had been five months since you'd
last one prior to yesterday is that
sound right something like that yeah
what goes through your mind through
those so you have that the high of
winning and then all of a sudden just
don't start to creep in when you don't
win even if you're in contention does
doubt start to creep in
a little bit it's such a it's such a
weird game because just you don't know
what ever is gonna happen you know it's
you don't know if you know you don't
know if you're gonna win five times this
year you don't know if you're not gonna
win any you don't know animistic odd I
mean it's it's such a crazy game and
that's what I love and hate about at the
same time is that it's all on me using
control and all I can do is prepare the
best that I can and my team you know get
my knee as ready as possible and for
whenever we tee it up that Thursday to
have our have the best chance that we
can to win and you know I tried to get a
lot better kind of accepting the results
and understanding that everything else
that happens after I hit the shot is out
of my control and all I can do is just
control what I can and that's kind of
preparation I'm ready to go and yeah it
was nice to have nice to do another one
after a little bit of a I guess you
could call it a drought I didn't know
this I knew it after the fact but it it
looked like you were getting emotional
when you put your head down and then I
find out your grandparents are there did
you come close to losing it when you saw
your grandparents yeah it was it was a
car that was I was over I mean that my
parents had been there for her you know
a handful my wind so it wasn't there's
no offense to them but it wasn't seeing
that when I got me choked up it just was
I looked over and saw Grandma and
Grandpa stand in their hand it just was
I just got a knot in my throat and I
knew if I if I looked at him any longer
and I thought anymore I was going to
lose it apply at the pot so I just
needed to I need to wrap her ass get
myself together and I need to try to
make that pot because I wanted to finish
on a good note and yeah it definitely
was an emotional win he's Justin Thomas
PGA golf or defending champ at the PGA
Championship I saw where you're paired
with Tiger and Rory now that's a
compliment to put you in a featured
group but when you play you know would
you rather not play with Tiger because
because of everything that goes along
with that or would you rather play with
him oh it's fine you know I've been
fortunate where
play I've been in some some really cool
groups the past year so and it's a part
of it I'll tell you one thing playing
with them there's a lot better than
playing the group in front or behind
because you're dealing with the crowds
you know running up on you while you're
trying to play or the crowds you know
even when you're kind of running up
ahead when you're still trying to hit so
it's it is what it is you know everybody
is looking with this plays with them
around of them it's you know it's gonna
be fun for me it's not going to be too
fun so my friends and family that are
out the wash because they're not very
much but uh but you know I I really
really enjoy playing with both Rory and
Tiger so it'll be a lot of fun I know
you went to Alabama but who was your pro
football team growing up I liked the
Bengals there you know growing up a
little I don't have any professional
team so I my fan bases are kind of all
over the place but there's about as
close as I can get but in terms of NFL I
I just I love football and I like a lot
of teams and a lot of certain players
but FATA to see my character with the
Bengals do do fantasy football I sure do
with other guys on tour yeah I do with a
group of friends down in Jupiter as some
of the guys are golfers and you know a
couple of guys are but Kali tomahawk
Galan is in there so it's just yeah we
have a good time if you get the pants
are going have you played golf with Nick
Saban I have actually yeah I played with
some and I think May it was I I go to a
a charity event and so every year I have
the last four years or so hand and I
can't win a little early this year and I
got together with Coach Saban and co-ceo
my golf coach and his son Jackson it was
it was a fun Walker how good is Nick
saving as a golfer he's a good player
he's competitive I know that I really uh
probably gonna be shocked to hear that
pretty quick and we put we put a little
bit off on coach and his son so it was
it was fun yeah he's a good player so he
recruited you on the
first tee right yeah I guess you could
say that he's a pretty good recruiter so
uh uh the thing about him is I'm never
gonna go against anything he says who
decides on these road trips when you go
with Ricky and Spieth like who's the
ringleader here it really depends you
know I mean Jordan's probably the least
organized of all of us so his trips are
very last-minute but we did have a nice
little trip it was British that that was
plans I am so that was fun but um a lot
of it at Ricky and I it's easy for us to
plan because I mean we live on the same
street
we're live in Jupiter where I mean were
work together I mean probably 80% of the
days of on the course of entire year so
there's spent a lot of time and kind of
ideals with your turn and every once in
a while and we both we both know when
we're kind of Jones and is ready for a
trip so we definitely planned a trip or
two together you ever got angry at each
other I don't I'm sure he's gotten angry
at me but it has it hasn't said it you
know Rick's one of the one of the nicest
guys I've ever met us it's a quality
that uh it's it's pretty hard to have
I've never really heard him say anything
bad about anybody and that's uh that's
pretty hard to do so I envy that about
him and it's I don't know if he's ever
been mad at me he has it verbally or
physically showing it but maybe he said
fiance or something if we played 18 and
had beers Fowler Spieth and you who wins
not Jordan he's lame
no it's not that it just Jordan isn't
isn't as good at the casual talk you
know he's very obviously he's
unbelievable at the competitive and
tournament golf but you know when we got
I'm play for fun or you know we go play
in Bahamas or whatever it may be you
know he doesn't play as well I think he
just has a hard time getting focused or
whatever it may be but bricks pretty
good at that casual just go out and take
take a couple beers and play and he's
he's pretty tough to beat he's pretty
tough to beat when he's not having beers
either but good luck in in st. Louis
it's
would be so hot and humid there right
it's gonna be hot oh and the ball is
gonna go further right I could yeah you
know the humidity might make it go a
little bit shorter in the mornings the
ones that once it starts really heating
up and the midday and afternoon but yeah
the balls got it's gonna fly what if I
said 90 degrees or 55 degrees um 55 is
pretty nice you just throw a little
little cashmere sweater on and you can
have a nice little day once we get below
50 though I don't want any part of it
how many white belts do you have Justin
zero good good I'm not that is breaking
news Justin Thomas has no white belts
yeah it's not a good look it's not a
good no no eh who has the most white
belts by the way I'm wondering the most
white belts does Ian Poulter have the
most white belts no Rick Rick wears a
white belt but he wears it correctly I
think if you wear it you need to wear it
with white pants I don't think it looks
too bad with that but you know it's I
don't need to get into a whole fashion
and pointing fingers here but yeah sure
sure
Titus shirt on tour belongs to Titus
shirt hmm I'm gonna go with probably
Billy Horschel or Jason Day data but but
they're also both a lot stronger than I
am so I can't really relate to the tight
shirt thing Mickelson's in there Justin
yeah I don't know if you saw on that new
commercial you know bigger search now
where he can move so you know he knows
what he's doing and the shirt department
now you're probably not gonna get these
questions this week but thank you for
indulging us with you have fun Congrats
yesterday and we appreciate your time
thank you that's just
Thoms he won yesterday he's only 25 he's
got nine wins on tour and he's your PGA
champ
the defending champ for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]